science mission I am going to highlight
some of the scientific research that is
making news in the last 24 to 48 hours
researchers report in face of journal is
surprising discovery that smell and
taste receptors normally found in the
nose and mouth can also be present on
the heart when the authors activated one
of the taste receptors with the bitter
chemical contractile function of the
heart was almost completely inhibited
next researchers have shown in the
journal Nature that epicardium outer
layer of the zebrafish heart regenerates
in a wave-like fashion and that sonic
hedgehog signaling helps in this event a
family of proteins known as histones
provide support and structure to the DNA
oddball histone h3 point 3 varies from
its regular counterpart h3 by only few
amino acids and its specific biological
role is not known authors in the journal
Nature found that H 3.3 appeared at a
certain type of repetitive sequence
called retrotransposons or are jumping
genes which are leftovers from ancient
viral infections the transpose ohms can
still copy themselves jump to new
locations and cause harmful mutations
Eastern 3.3 binds to retro transpose
ohms silences them and prevents
chromosomal abnormalities for more
details visitors at www sense mission
calm or our science mission facebook
page thanks for watching